so once you knew you were going to be
the showrunner for home improvement you
did a lot of research you prepared you
show up you're now facing this room of
writers most of whom you know how are
you dealing with that and was it as you
imagined well first of all I gave them
all homework it's like kids in school
today now they have to redo reading over
the summer my aside they had assignments
their assignments were to come in with
maybe four to six stories a piece or
three stories of piece I don't remember
what it was but everybody had to come in
with and deliver something and so
already you have just a bunch of stuff
to work with
I had stories that I brought in and all
my writers had stories so we had a lot
to talk about
and so they had stories and the other
thing that you talk about on day one
really before you even get into the
stories is the arc of the season what's
gonna happen at the beginning and the
episode one of the season and what's
gonna happen in episode 22 or 24 however
many we were doing and once you kind of
setup that general art then you get to
the stories because the arc tells you
where you want the characters to go so
the stories that these writers come in
with they're not that worked out because
first you have to decide on your arc and
where you want your characters to go but
I'm pretty confident that all of us came
in with stories that then actually did
fit in with the arc or we could tweak to
the arc and you know that's how we got
started so you ideally you get started
with just a burst of energy and
everybody's really excited to be there
it's the first day of work people are
getting paid to be writers in television
in Hollywood and it's a privilege how do
you know you're keeping the story moving
forward was there were there times when
you thought you were doing things that
were great jokes were funny but then you
stood back and said the story isn't
moving forward well you know in
traditional multi-camera sitcom there's
always the tendency to do to make it too
many jokes and slow down the scene
because you think you're being so funny
with all the jokes people are telling
but it becomes pretty evident along the
way if people are just standing around
telling jokes and the story isn't being
served so and then if you have a staff
of good people
somebody's gonna something gonna say hey
don't we need to get to this story
points sooner and could we cut this so
that that's very common speaking of
cutting I'm thinking of let's say
Three's Company and sometimes like mr.
Roper would come in and it was just a
look he didn't have to say a word and
you already knew he was either judging
Jack Tripper or somebody how did you
know sometimes said you know what let's
just do it as a look was that when the
actor well Tim Allen you know when you
work with somebody who the audience
loves you get so many extra laughs what
looks like that so you know as a show
grows you realize who's you know a look
on a certain line you know he's going to
get a laugh so in home improvement the
thing that made that show a success Tim
Allen was very successful comedian but
the thing that made the show a success
was coming up with a worthy adversary to
play his wife and witch who was Patricia
Richardson and we knew that if we wrote
a scene and he did something stupid and
she gave him a look the audience
especially the women that we're gonna go
there they were gonna love it so you
know you learn about those looks and and
what what they're gonna wasn't going to
give you comedic lee in fact we did a
whole show a little episode of home
improvement called the look and what
that was one of the writers came in with
this idea and it was based on just the
look that your wife gives you when you
act like an idiot and so this whole
thing was the episode was called the
look and it featured a very funny comic
named Blake Clark and he played the
owner of a hardware store and home
and his wife played by a very funny ex
groundling named Shirley pres Tia and he
would talk about the look that he would
get and I guess we did stuff with Tim
and his his wife at home but with Blake
and Shirley she would give him she had
one of those looks she'd give him the
look the audience would go crazy and
then he'd give the look back and Tim was
in the scene too and he'd be looking at
them giving them the giving each other
look and the last just they spread they
I mean no dialogue at all the laugh
every time the director knew when to cut
from look - look - look - look and the
and the laughter just built like crazy
was a really funny episode do you think
that's what distinguishes a lot of new
writers versus more seasoned is knowing
when to cut out some of the jokes and to
go to the looks you know it was what
distinguishes watching a show grow
because you don't know when you start a
show what what's gonna hit from which
actors so it's learning the the whole
thing it's not just what's on the page
it's what's on the stage so if the if
the actors are really gifted physically
and you start to see audiences reacting
or even in a single camera show you can
tell if somebody's reaction is just
hysterical and you know you make a
mental note of that and then you start
to use that but it usually grows from
seeing the actors work with the material
forgiveme didn't that happen with a show
that you did called duet where two stars
started out as the main characters and
then it was that was a whole other whole
other bit of business I mean that was
duet was on the when the Fox Network
first started and we followed married
with children which was a huge hit and
we did okay it was a pretty funny show
the audience is the the studio the
network they like the show but they felt
that the two leads weren't as funny as
these two side characters
so it was one of these really weird
situations where the two side characters
became the lead characters of the show
and then one of the main characters
stayed in the show but one didn't it was
bizarre it was really bizarre and that
was the first sitcom first acting job
for Ellen DeGeneres she was in she was
in the spin-off of duet called
open house playing a secretary in a real
estate office oh I bet that was funny
and the other person it was between
Ellen DeGeneres and Paula Poundstone oh
and they were both hilarious
you